Salut romain ça va ouais et toi ton tatouages ah pfff c'est quand même dingue en 2018 on n'est toujours pas trouvé un truc qui marche
bah en fait on a peut-être trouvé un truc mais (ah ouais quoi?) bon attends je vais t'expliquer
Ya un peu plus d'un an maintenant
je me suis fait tatouer et j'en ai fait une vidéo je suis presque sûr que vous en souvenez
moi en tout cas je m'en souviens bien... Dans cette vidéo je donnais des explications sur le tatouage, et notamment sur la raison pour laquelle
l'encre reste en place sous la peau, et je disais ça:
En plus les cellules qui sont chargés de faire le ménage dans le derme qu'on appelle des macrophages
elles arrivent pas à évacuer les pigments de l'encre parce qu'ils sont trop fat (gros) pour elle
Du coup l'encre, elle reste sur place et finit par être absorbé par d'autres cellules qu'on appelle des fibroblastes
et qui gardent la couleur sur place, sans bouger. Alors à l'époque c'était l'explication la plus communément admise,
mais il y a eu une découverte toute récente qui est venue changer la donne: une équipe de chercheurs de l'inserm du cnrs et de l'université
d'aix marseille s'est penchée sur la questio,n et leurs résultats ont été publiés dans le journal of experimental medicine
(c'est de l'anglais) les médias du monde entier en ont parlé et comme je l'ai dit dans une vidéo précédente
Vous avez été très très très très nombreuses et très très nombreux à m'envoyer
plein d'articles, du coup j'ai contacté un des chercheurs en question qui s'appelle Bernard Malissen il m'a tout bien expliqué et moi
je vais vous raconter. Donc jusqu'ici on pensait que les pigments injectés sous la peau était trop gros pour être évacués par les macrophages
qui sont censés faire le ménage et que du coup ils étaient fixés dans les fibroblastes qui sont des cellules de notre derme
mais ce que suggère la découverte des chercheurs c'est qu'en réalité ce qui se passe c'est que les macrophages
ils absorbent quand même l'encre sans pouvoir l'évacuer et qu'après ils restent sur place avec le bide plein de pigments (rot) donc en fait c'est eux
les macrophages qui gardent la couleur en place, et pas les fibroblastes. Et encore pire, ils ont découvert que les macrophages
bon ils sont pas immortels, quand il y en a un qui meurt
il relâche l'encre, et il y en a un autre qui arrive qui re absorbe l'encre, et qui reste sur place
donc c'est sans fin. Attends ça veut dire que le macrophage il mange ce que son pote mort vient de vomir ?
Bon, c'est peut-être pas les même conventions sociales chez les macrophages, on va pas les juger. En plus de nous aider à comprendre comment l'encre
des tatouages reste en place, cette découverte  pourrait aussi avoir des applications
sur le détatouage, et là vous comprenez qu'en plus d'éveiller ma curiosité d'un point de vue théorique,
ça m'intéresse aussi d'un point de vue plus pratique,
et plus personnel. En gros tout ça ça remet en cause la théorie selon laquelle c'est les macrophages qui
évacuent les fragments d'encre une fois qu'elle a été explosée par le laser. En vérité, a priori ils gardent aussi en place les petites particules
explosées qu'ils arrivent à re bouffer. Quand j'en ai discuté avec Bernard Malissen, il m'a expliqué que c'était possible
qu'en fait les fragments d'encre, ils soient captés par d'autres cellules du système immunitaire
et évacués par le réseau lymphatique, qui s'occupe aussi des bactéries, et des virus. Du coup, l'idée pour leur permettre de bosser tranquillement ce serait
d'inactiver temporairement les macrophages sur la zone du tatouage, pour éviter qu'ils re bouffent directement l'encre quand elle a été exposée par le laser.
OK mais, comment on fait ça ? Les chercheurs pensent qu'ils pourraient produire des anticorps qu'on appelle des anticorps monoclonaux, et qui sont capables
de reconnaître les molécules qui se trouvent sur les macrophages,
et d'aller se fixer dessus. Sur ces anticorps, ils grefferaient une toxine capable d'inactiver les macrophages pour une durée limitée.
Et alors comment est-ce qu'on enverrait tout ça précisément au contact de l'encre ? Et bah l'idée ce serait d'appliquer le produit avec les anticorps
sur la peau, au niveau du tatouage et de le faire pénétrer dans le derme avec...
un laser. Alors,  pas le même laser que pour le détatouage
ce serait un laser qui est utilisé en cosmétique, et qui est capable de faire des micro trous dans la peau, ce qui permettrait aux anticorps de
pénétrer. Alors ça a l'air d'être de la science fiction comme ça, mais en vrai c'est une technique qui est déjà
expérimentée pour faire des vaccins sans injection par exemple. Une fois que les anticorps se sont fixés sur les macrophages,
et que la toxine leur a fermé leur clapet, il reste plus qu'à passer un coup de laser là dessus
pour exploser l'encre. Le laser de détatouage hein, celui qu'on connaît bien...
Surtout moi...
Après, il reste plus qu'à laisser faire le système lymphatique
qui doit évacuer tout ça. Alors je sais, vous allez me dire "oui mais tout ça c'est du conditionnel"
Bah oui parce que même si les chercheurs sont très confiants sur les chances de réussite de la technique,
elle n'a pas été testée. Alors vous pensez bien hein, moi mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour, je me suis dit "je vais me proposer comme
sujet humain pour l'expérimentation" sauf que... sauf que ce genre
d'expérimentations, ça prend du temps,
ça coûte de l'argent et qu'en l'occurrence les chercheurs ils n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre, parce que c'était pas du tout ce qui était prévu
au programme au départ. Du coup bah ça ira pas plus loin,
enfin pas de leur côté en tout cas
Alors peut-être qu'un jour il y a quelqu'un qui mettra de l'argent pour financer ça, et mettre au point une méthode révolutionnaire de détatouage,
mais pour le moment...
J'suis à deux doigts d'ouvrir un ulule moi... Du coup moi je vais devoir trouver une autre solution pour mon petit cas personnel
alors, en vrai, j'ai déjà trouvé. Je vais vous en reparler très bientôt. Bon voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo, d'ici là
mettez  vous bien, et surtout portez vous bien
(The end)